ahora voy a introducirlos al concepto de
tensión
la tensión realmente solo es la fuerza
que es aplicada por por una cuerda o
digamos por un cable cuando está
levantando o empujando un objeto vamos
vamos a poner digamos esto en un en un
ejemplo concreto digamos que tengo una
masa aquí digamos que tengo una masa
aquí ok no sé pues de alguna caja o qué
sé yo y digamos que esta masa de aquí
tiene un peso de 100 newtons ok digamos
que tiene un peso de 100 newtons muy
bien entonces esto tiene un peso de 100
newtons y vamos a dejar que esta masa
esté colgando de algún cable digamos que
esté colgando de algún cable y este es
el techo ok entonces este cable está
soportando de este peso de 100 newtons
ok pero este peso está en reposo es
decir no está acelerando ok lo que
importa es que no está acelerando
digamos si está colgado pues uno no
imagina que está que esta caja sigue
acelerando hacia el centro de la tierra
por efectos de la gravedad entonces si
no está acelerando
debe haber alguna fuerza que esté
contrarrestando la fuerza de gravedad
recordemos que la fuerza de gravedad es
una fuerza digamos que digamos que
aplicamos desde aquí ok entonces tenemos
una fuerza hacia abajo
déjenme ponerlo así esta es una fuerza
de gravedad
ok esta es la fuerza de gravedad que es
de 100 newtons y que va hacia hacia el
centro de la tierra pero si este objeto
está en reposo debido a que cuelga por
una cuerda entonces debe haber una
fuerza en dirección contraria que esté
contrarrestando la fuerza de gravedad
muy bien déjenme ponerlo con verde
ahí lo tienen esta fuerza que va en
dirección contraria a la fuerza de
gravedad es lo que podemos entender como
tensión y es una fuerza que está impresa
debido a esta cuerda ok la atención
esencialmente es la fuerza de la cuerda
y de la cuerda perdón que lo mantiene
sin acelerar a este objeto ok entonces
uno podría tratar de contextualizar lo o
tratar de ponerlo en situaciones de la
vida cotidiana y puedes imaginarte una
guitarra verdad una guitarra en alguna
de las cuerdas mientras más tensa lo
hagas digamos mientras más mientras lo
aprietes de forma que se tensa más
produce un sonido más agudo verdad uno
tiene aquí la guitarra y tiene aquí
estas divisiones y si una presión aquí o
acá s
la cuerda se pone más tensa que en este
lugar entonces eso produce sonidos mucho
más agudos y eso es debido a la al
efecto de la atención o también puedes
pensar en cuando uno quiere comprar
ciertos cables no sé quizás para
construcciones
quizás porque vas a hacer un columpio
qué sé yo uno tiene que verificar muy
bien cuál es la tensión que soporta una
cuerda para que el objeto que esté
cargando no no la rompa verdad entonces
espero que al menos esto sea intuitivo
el concepto de tensión pero vamos a ver
un ejemplo mucho más complicado
digamos que aquí ya no está el techo
aunque este no es el techo sino a lo
mejor está atado no sé digamos algún
punto y que voy a marcar con rojo porque
va a ser muy importante y digamos que
además de todo hay una cuerda que va de
este punto al techo y ahora el techo va
a estar aquí vamos a no sé vamos a
pintarlo de esta forma ahí esté el techo
ok digamos que este es el techo déjenos
hacerlo un poquito más derechito más o
menos y digamos además que aquí tenemos
una pared
y ahí está una pared y para que esto se
mantenga en equilibrio vamos a poner una
cuerda también que se ata a este lado de
este muro muy bien entonces ahí ya
tenemos dos cuerdas estas dos cuerdas
cada una va a imprimir cierta tensión
vamos a ponerle a esta tensión uno ya
esta tensión dos ok entonces lo que
tenemos que observar es que este punto
rojo es en donde todos están sosteniendo
aquí tenemos esta cuerda azul también
todo esto se
todo esto se mantiene estacionario
verdad
entonces para para fines de que el
ejercicio sea mucho más sencillo vamos a
suponer que los cables no tienen peso ok
sólo para por simplicidad y en realidad
no puede argumentar que estos cables a
lo mejor son muy ligeros verdad tan
ligeros que no no no tienen mayor
influencia digamos ok entonces para
tratar de entender por qué este punto no
se mueve tenemos que hacer algunas cosas
por ejemplo este punto tiene un bueno
esta está siendo afectado por la fuerza
de gravedad que es el imprime a este a
este cuerpo verdad entonces aquí hay una
fuerza de gravedad una fuerza de
gravedad y que ya dijimos que es de 100
newtons este es de 100 newtons verdad
entonces si tenemos esta fuerza de
gravedad y este punto es estacionario
debe haber alguna fuerza que sea que
vaya hacia arriba verdad es decir en
dirección contraria a la fuerza de
gravedad que anule lo que es la fuerza
de gravedad y eso viene justamente de
esta cuerda que imprime
de 1 vamos a hacerlo de esta forma vamos
a descomponer este t 1 esta fuerza t 1
en dos fuerzas una que va hacia la
derecha y una que va hacia arriba ok en
esencialmente estamos descomponiendo en
su parte horizontal y en su parte pep en
vertical perdón entonces si a ésta le
llamamos digamos la fuerza t 1 pero en
la dirección x aunque es la dirección
horizontal ya la otra le llamamos t 1 en
la dirección de y todo esto son vectores
recordemos entonces ya hemos
descompuesto esta esta fuerza t 1 en 2
que además de todos son perpendiculares
verdad y para fines de este ejercicio
vamos a suponer que el ángulo con el al
cual digamos está atado esta esta cuerda
es de 30 grados entonces uno podría
utilizar trigonometría para saber que
como éste está esta línea digamos que
representa el techo
de la fuerza horizontal o la componente
horizontal de la fuerza t 1 son
paralelos como son paralelos entonces
este ángulo es de 30 grados ya que esta
es una línea transversal verdad entonces
lo que tenemos ya es un ángulo y las
componentes de este vector entonces
podríamos utilizar funciones
trigonométricas para recordar cómo
calcular cada uno de estos por ejemplo
podríamos podríamos recordar la técnica
está esta técnica del zocato a su cato a
y que nos dice por ejemplo aquí tenemos
un ángulo y digamos que queremos ver
cómo relacionar nuestra componente
vertical verdad porque ésta es la única
componente vertical en todo este
diagrama que tenemos y eso es importante
porque está apunta hacia la derecha está
apunta hacia la izquierda verdad es una
fuerza que se le imprime hacia la
izquierda entonces la única fuerza
vertical que tenemos es la componente yo
la componente vertical
uno de la fuerza de uno verdad y está
justo es la que debe medir 100 newtons
para que se se anule con la fuerza de
gravedad entonces cuál es la única
relación trigonométricas perdón función
trigonométricas que me relaciona la el
lado opuesto con la hipotenusa pues es
justamente el seno verdad entonces lo
que tendremos es lo siguiente
seno de 30 grados es igual a la magnitud
de la componente 71 dividido entre la
norma de tf1
la norma o la magnitud de tf1 entonces
si uno quiere conocer quién es la la
magnitud de la componente vertical de
tf1 simplemente despejamos entonces
tenemos que la magnitud de t 1 por el
seno de 30 grados es igual a la magnitud
de t 1 en la componente vertical verdad
y esto sabemos que tiene que ser 100
newtons estos deben ser 100 newtons
porque deben anularse con la fuerza de
gravedad entonces simplemente ya podemos
calcular cuál es la magnitud de la
tensión 1 verdad que corresponde a esta
primera cuerda y eso es porque el seno
de 30 grados es un medio verdad hay que
hay que repasar lo de las funciones
trigonométricas y lo que tenemos es que
la magnitud de tf1
por un medio por un medio es igual a 100
newtons es igual a 100 newtons y por lo
tanto esto nos dice que la magnitud de
tf1 si multiplicamos por dos de ambos
lados verdad esto es igual a 200 newtons
muy bien entonces esta es la fuerza de
magnitud que tiene de 1 esta primera
cuerda ahora recordemos que t 2 también
se debe anular con todas las fuerzas que
sean horizontales pero si nos damos
cuenta solo tenemos una que es la
componente horizontal
dt 1 verdad la t1 x que aquí pusimos
entonces lo que tenemos es que la
magnitud de t 2 debe ser igual a la
magnitud de t 1 x
de verdad y esto lo podemos obtener
fácilmente porque esto simplemente es
utilizando ahora el coseno esto lo
podemos ver de la misma forma como de
uno de uno la magnitud de uno por el
coseno de treinta grados y esto no es
otra cosa más que la magnitud de tf1 que
son 200 newtons 200 minutos 200 newtons
por el coseno de 30 grados que eso sí si
recuerdas es raíz de 3 entre 2 ok
entonces esto nos da simplemente la
cantidad de 200 entre 2 son 100 raíz de
3 newtons verdad entonces ahora sabemos
que te 2
t 2 es una fuerza de 100 raíz de 3
newtons y hay que decir como este es un
vector que va a hacia la izquierda esto
es hacia la izquierda
izquierda mientras que de 1 x de 1 x es
una fuerza de 100 raíz de tres minutos
pero estos van hacia la derecha y espero
que haya quedado esto muy claro